this podcast and every other podcast on
my channel is funded by our supporters
on patreon this episode is actually also
about five minutes longer on patreon
boys weren't recording video to start
with but i decided it's worth keeping as
the patreon version so you can go get
exclusive content if you want to check
that out too now to the show hi
hey alana oh i like your shirt i'm in
the middle of a story we're in a story
but we are recording videos we are not
recording it's one of those videos i
apologize
i said we should do video it's a
professional show
it's like oh it's weird like what i know
yeah yeah i know
i i found out they were like you need an
adult and i went yeah it's it's all
still i can't do it either way don't
trust it wait so we have no video no no
no so i record through obs but the zoom
calls hi everyone welcome to play watch
listen
um there's like this weird thing about
the recurring meeting is that it says we
have to ask a host for permission for
permission is that god but none of us
are considered a host
let's pray heavenly father it's like a
fifth member of the podcast
to give you permission who is please
come and let us
fill us with your it's definitely a data
record 100 okay well i am i we have to
go back to troy's story because it's
about a drunken encounter with david
cage so
oh i have sorry about that paging doctor
you just can't wait for this [ __ ] let's
go so first of all i learned i learned
something about myself i
i thought i was really really good in
interviews
and i came back and
ashley is just
there's a very protective nature and
relationship that i have with ashley
like that's we very quickly fell into
those roles
um
and and so she was like i need i'm
scared i need help
i don't i don't like being on camera
believe it or not i don't like doing
those interviews so can you help me i
was like sure
so all of the interviews they'd be like
you know troy what's like playing joel
or whatever and ashley what's it like
playing ellie and she'd be like
you know and and she would give great
answers but
what people saw from the interviews is
me jumping in and speaking for her and
neil pointed that out he was like
i need you to yeah you need to be aware
of this i was like i know exactly what
you were doing but i need you to see how
it looks and i was like thank you for
showing it to me that's thoughtful for
him to tell him yeah it's incredibly
thoughtful and and i that that's
that's one of
the many many moments when he's been my
friend and going i know your heart but
you need to see how this looks
and he was like you need to trust the
fact that this isn't live
they can edit it they can take out those
pauses and cut to game play and and just
pull out like man you're absolutely
right and i started watching him and how
he is in interviews and i learned a lot
from him because if you'll ever watch
him they'll go what are you hoping uh
people will think of the hbo series it
goes
what do i think
he takes a shot people yeah and he
reiterated so repeating the question is
this
i was like what a great active listening
thing and um it also it makes it easier
for them to cut it if you for sure if
you repeat the question yeah and
somebody said
i can't remember who it was that told me
this and i wish i could give them credit
because it was really helpful but
they're like a bite and a button that's
all they need they need a byte that they
can lead off with for the headline and
they need a button to get out of your
interview so don't go and uh you know i
mean that's kind of yeah that's what i
it's the most amazing thing i've ever
seen it's like no we need to be able to
take the bite and get the button that's
all you need right bite in a button
that's one of them
like i used to do these mini
documentaries it was my favorite thing
to do at ign
which i think probably is why i ended up
on the part that i'm on is that we used
to go to studios and interview a whole
bunch of people and like actually see
you know the game in the development
process um they were really really fun
to make
and there were some people who would
like just clearly not
uh press trained um like the problem
would be that
no matter how many times you would tell
them they would answer the question
without
uh
starting this question in any way like
so if i'm gonna ask you like you know
why is her hair like this it's like that
because it's red i'm like i literally
have to cut that straight away the
reason why her hair is red is because we
decided that we wanted to do this right
what are you really excited about
ultimately when you're thinking about
the color of a character's head
and that's why we have mike on the show
i just pointed to mike biffle
i did like three days of intensive media
training like in an early job because
they wanted to do something
it's such good it's such a good ski you
should just quit i got nowhere else to
go
there are also just like some gross
things that media will do that i think
comes with um that's harder to train
that you have to learn over time is like
yeah unfortunately you have to walk into
one of those traps in order to learn
they are really looking for a sound bite
for certain things and like some
questions are being asked because
they're planning to write a specific
headline because they know that's what
will generate clicks and it that can be
do you think the last of us part two is
the most controversial game and can you
please and what that phrase
what's your thoughts on currently
popular controversy i'm sorry i'm not
really caught up on any of that um but
uh do you feel that crunch culture is
here to
like every time that i get an interview
request where somebody's asking me to
talk about sexism i say no
because there are so many um it would be
majority of them they asked me to talk
about tell me about how badly women are
treated and it's been that way for a
really long time and i'm always like no
um so now if anyone wants to interview
me i'm like don't ask me about this
because at a certain point it's all any
woman who ever gets interviewed talks
about and i'm at a point now where i
would much prefer to talk about here's
how i got where i am here's all the cool
women i work with and all the cool stuff
that we get to do please more women join
the industry and it it's so many and you
see the headline they're looking for
it's like women gamer abused again
as a journalist do you feel that i don't
feel this is a proper uh platform to
have that conversation is an appropriate
response to that or
like would you i hate to make you play
kind of devil's advocate but like would
you look at that and go troy baker
refuses to answer question or i never
did that kind of [ __ ] because my
interviews were always like about
business perspectives
you know how people are well so
yeah i would say
terrible terrible journalists like
i'm going to make up a name
greg miller i would say
generic
white american nation
to be clear greg miller is an acclaimed
voice actor he's not a journalist
he is
he is a master
he's possibly my favorite voice actor
i've ever looked yeah one of the best
he's just yeah he's just one of the best
the best i'd say what about i think if
he changed the
game um
i yeah i'm not really had to talk about
that today then yes you'd be fine
okay great that's so media training
trains you just to not answer
yeah if you're asked a controversial
question circle it just circle it go
somewhere else yeah
the other thing the other thing that
happened again
they won't write it basically if people
ask me the sexism question even when
i've asked them not to i just go ah come
on i just want to talk about the fun
stuff yes that's a facet of it but let's
let's keep talking about the positives
i'm really interested in getting more
women in the industry and then that's it
and also you answer in a way that
doesn't contain the questions so it's
harder to edit it like there's lots of
ways so if you want to avoid the thing
you can avoid when asked which is always
funnier when you see like some person
who's not very well media trained kind
of fall into a big trap which i know i'm
planting the seeds here for when i
inevitably do mess up an interview this
is the clip someone will send to me
i also had a couple of drinks in me and
uh when david cage and i were actually
finally introduced i wasn't the kindest
to him
yeah
i need to talk about that you don't need
to get into the details of it maybe this
is just his level of police
i made one of the documentary style
video things that i'm talking about um
at quantic
and uh david cage was
lovely
um very nice man
very like i think a little bit nervous
to have press in the office and this was
i think before the
inappropriate [ __ ] in the office was
found there
um wait was there an appropriate [ __ ]
found in the office and they i really
don't want to like myself
they found like
people had like photoshopped female
employees faces on the oh i don't
remember that pretty terrible
um like dude if somebody did that to me
i would have quit how uh jesus correct
anyway um we went out to dinner
and
uh
david cage made me eat snail
um i wasn't interested he made me do it
and i spent that whole dinner trying to
figure out how to crack him i was like
how do i get this man to like open up
and and like be more
like more human and less businessy and
the way that i figured it out was uh to
talk about console wars
really just lit up david cage made him
made him a very different person he was
very enthusiastic
about talking about console wars
strong opinions
are there like the south park episodes
and i'm assuming you're talking about
just like the south park episode yeah
yeah 100 great three episodes you should
watch it
a lot of times passes and fire mike
looks like he's frozen but he's not he's
just no no he looks like he's just high
mike's been media trained
guys
mike's not available now
um what we were talking about alana
pierce i think you'd be very proud of
your boys
um is the fact that
there's so much [ __ ] that's that i want
to talk about
um dune awakening open world survival
game revealed
it's a lot oh it's gamescom today huh
yeah it's been a bit that's why
that's what led up two hours nonsense
yeah i was like nonsense but i actually
can talk about uh
pentament because the embargo is up
tomorrow morning so we'll be fine for
the show fentanyl
fun calm
uh
was that it was that in uh it was in
the xbox showcase and you'll recognize
it it's a historical narrative adventure
game not an rpg which is a thing that
they were really excited about when i
saw it um it's a passion project made by
a small team at obsidian 13 devs
which is like so cool and to me was like
this has got to be a game pass thing
like without game pass surely they
wouldn't have been able to do this um
and it's yeah it's basically all of the
art
is styled based on actual art from that
era like they took illuminated
manuscripts right like uh that's not
what the that's the phrasing they used
but it's art style is referenced from
early modern wood cuts and late
it is late medieval illumination
if i was gonna be mike bithell i would
go down and i have two illuminated
texts
there was a place in london where i fell
in love with them in their 15th century
italian that's all of them well that's
really cool
style and it's really cool also my pc is
really loud today sorry listeners you
might be able to do it
i probably need to put more cooling in
oh
pieces are always loud yeah it's
rattling for some reason so
yeah it's an unusual time and place for
for the game like i've never seen
anything in this era it's kind of like
the revolution of 1525 which is like i
don't know anything about anything in
that era and a really interesting thing
that um they were telling us about with
the hands-on preview was
everybody's religious in this period of
time
and i feel like i've never played a game
where
they have to be to be historically
accurate everybody has to be religious
so you are dealing with people while
you're solving uh murders a series of
murders but you don't have any dna
because it doesn't exist and everybody's
religious so you'll deal with some
people who might be like well that's
what god wanted
so it's going to be like a murder
mystery in a setting that almost opposes
solving
this sounds [ __ ] cool you need to
google cad cad file cad fell it's a
british it was a show when i was a kid a
british detective can procedure all set
during medieval times
is this a comedy it looks like brother
catfell is the main fictional character
in a series of historical murder
mysteries written between the 70s
by the linguist scholar
series of books based on a tv but sorry
a tv show based on a series of books but
it's played by dude
okay yeah he's awesome in there very
cool
similar idea like medieval detective
story yeah i'm really excited about it
like i always thought it looked cool and
it's very different from anything
obsidian's done before and that it's not
an rpg it's an adventure game um and
they have a lot of really cool
accessibility options as well because
they were talking about and i think
they're probably right
this game being appealing to people who
don't play video games so like
if someone's talking to you about a
certain character and you don't remember
that name you can immediately like click
on the name and it will just back up
into this um like glossary that will be
like it'll show you a picture of them
and remind you who they were and i was
like that [ __ ] rules that's a really
good idea for a murder mystery like
especially even if you're playing it for
half an hour and then you put it down
for two weeks and you're like wait who
is that
but they also had a lot of really good
accessibility stuff which i really
wanted to shout them out for
actually talking about in a preview a
lot of companies don't do that they're
like the disabled gamers can figure it
out on launch but they did it ahead of
time
um so there's obviously the glossary for
everything which is really really cool
and they've put a lot of effort into the
ui and their font rendering was like
fascinating like i would do a full
interview with them about font rendering
they have
one at a time and each letter is drawn
one stroke at a time and the whole thing
was done by hand
what yeah that's why and also it looks
like physical ink so when it comes on
it's all shiny and then it slowly dries
and the pages like bleed into each other
and some characters have different kind
of text based on what their jobs are
so that the text will change but while
having that they also still manage to
give you font scaling um and a bunch of
different font features for legibility
and readability and that stuff is like
not easy to do um no so they have to do
it from moment one exactly actually just
starting so happy to add it to our stuff
because we made an effort it's yeah why
it's it's fun scaling's one of those
things that's easy as long as you decide
to do it on the first day of development
if you do it late it's really hard like
god of war 2018 was criticized for the
font being too small and i think we've
never been able to add it post so we all
we're now doing that with future games
we're doing that from day one for that
reason yeah that's a nightmare it's
super cool and again just so happy that
they spoke about it um while also having
it like
you know clearly not take away from
anything there the um artistic vision
with the font is still really on point
like they have
uh scratches and corrections in the
parchment if somebody like corrects
themselves they'll still write it but
then they'll scratch it out and then
they'll go on it's like that's so cool
like i just thought the font stuff was
really really really neat and it's good
it's it's good that i love that they're
talking about that in the context of
like
it establishes the artistic vision can
be maintained while doing the accessible
stuff and it's suppressed
as an excuse
because that's yeah exactly you always
you always see people rarely game
developers normally audience members
saying oh well we don't want to
compromise the but it's always what the
devs wanted no you can you can do both
sorry trolls
examples oh no no it always uh i think
the challenge of not having it feel
tacked on or a feature as opposed to
having to be baked into the game and and
um to me is always the goal i don't i
don't think that anybody who's going to
use those features wants to feel like
and we did this for you
um as opposed to no we've just built our
experience
to where it is truly accessible to
everybody
um i think that's always the goal things
that get me about like a lot of the
accessibility conversations i could rant
about this forever i made a whole award
show about it um
is people saying i don't need
accessibility but then when they're
sitting on their tv and the fonts too
small and they don't think to go into
the accessibility menu and make the font
bigger you everybody needs accessibility
all the time i've made this thing before
but people need to think ahead a bit
more because i want to be playing games
in retirement and this is not going to
be working
in the same way as in two years
menu is a great example of an
accessibility option in the context of
some disabilities can be temporary
temporary disability um is a
a couple who's just had their first
child that is a temporary disability in
that you are currently not able to do
things that would require your attention
you can't play elden ring unless you can
pause the boss fight you've got to stop
you have to have the ability to stop
that's an accessibility option for
somebody in that circumstance like a
circumstantial disability that's not
permanent there's still a lot of [ __ ]
people like yeah i think the the
conflation of accessibility being to
someone who is in a wheelchair or who is
blind or something like that as opposed
to
no there's just like you said
that your life is going to change and
you want the
i don't think that games should always
be like how easy can we make it but i
think building it into the narrative
building it into
the design of it is is always the goal
yeah i'm really really proud of the
accessibility team for god of war
ragnarok that the amount of
accessibility options is like
so impressive and can i ask like how big
how big is an accessibility team on a
triple-a game now it's like how many
people can use can you answer that like
i don't know
it's not that big but it wasn't that big
with naughty dog
so it's multiple people multiple people
some of the same people some of the
people on our team came from uh last of
us part two so yeah there was like i
think there was i don't want to be
misquoted so please if anyone knows the
answer to this if there's someone from
the the the studio watching listening or
playing um
i think it was like four people that
sounds right that's what i was saying
that we're like that sounds pretty much
right but that's really cool because aaa
can afford to do that like obviously in
an indie scale like we can't have one
we can't have one person dedicated to
this but the idea that aaa can kind of
set these standards that we can then
duplicate cheaper right is great but the
amount of robustness that those systems
had
and neil even says he was like they were
so passionate about i was like okay we
can do this much and they were like
we're kind of gonna go further with it
and really really ratcheted it up that's
that's what's impressive to me yeah yeah
our stability team is like
like they will do they will not stop
ever they're like we will do as much as
we possibly can and i've never seen like
a group of people that dedicated and and
to anybody on the team who has any kind
of disability they're like what do you
need what can we do
what's the problem and then they'll be
like like two days later they'll be like
does this would this solve the problem
and they're like yeah they're like let's
try and implement it and then suddenly
it's like hey it's in like it's it's so
cool this this so so so impressive
there's a blog post a fascinating cross
discipline as well presumably and again
i'm guessing here i know you can't
confirm any of this but you would have
to have like a designer a coder an
artist like it's an interesting
intersection just inside that team
yeah it's like a it's a commando unit
right it's the it's it's a uh it's uh
what's his name um
i got it with those two notes
thank you just say hey that wasn't what
i expected i'm so proud of you right now
just just move over here
but it is that thing of like you you
have that it's been really um
interesting and again like i guess it's
similarly cagey to you alana but like
hiring in some people recently we hide
in a designer who basically did
um was on such a team within a bigger
studio before where she was just working
with just like you know one of
everything essentially and they would be
brought in to do one big job and then
get out and it's just a fascinating it's
almost like triple a now has
it's adopted kind of almost a more indie
approach of having little siloed teams
that can kind of move around and help
different people and do different things
it's really it's just it's interesting
seeing that cross-pollination and then
it works backwards that like all of that
r d that triple a can spend money on
with this stuff i can pick up a copy of
god of war for
fifty dollars and i can
i can absolutely kind of copy every good
idea in there for accessibility and and
i get that
essentially yeah i mean it definitely
was uh like cross studio i imagine at
least um with
like last of us part two having more
accessibility options than any game ever
worth noting um
saints row also is extremely accessible
i feel like there's a lot of negativity
surrounding that game but also very very
very accessible there i saw like all the
screen shots from someone on twitter
like yeah yeah as well yeah they did it
there's
there's people and not to focus on the
negative when you are clearly uh
underlined are you in positive troy oh
no oh okay no no no all new team
uh which is fine
but
why
yeah why are they
why are they getting such uh
shade as it were like what what's
i i've just seen
yes
it's been an interesting one
i don't think the game is very good
however i'm a little bit conflicted in
seeing
some of the reviewers um and this is not
the more important part the game
there i could list you a long list of
reasons why it's not very good but um
is
some of the reviewers are the same
people on twitter who are like stop
being mean to devs but then their
reviews are like so clearly reveling in
not enjoying it
some of it's like damn you went real
hard on this of course be honest like
100 but some of it's like oh did you
need to like make that almost personal
we've all had reviews like that where
you're like you didn't like it but you
didn't need to like install enjoy not
liking it yeah and i like when i i was
playing the first hour and my
impressions are negative and i was just
like man i feel i just feel bad for this
team i'm sure they worked really hard on
this and i it feels to me like it had a
really low budget but they were still
trying to make a big budget game and so
there's a disconnect you can see
[ __ ] they they also bought it pretty
cheap you know so it's it's not like
there was a lot i don't know if they're
using existing assets i don't know it's
it it i didn't think that it was being
built from the ground up
you've got a horrible truth of most
video games as they're made from the
ground up unless it's the same team
working in the same engine on that team
yeah exactly so they all have built a
lot from the ground up like okay there's
so much um
well even if you get the tech even if
you get all the assets so much of what
makes a game a game is the knowledge of
the team that made it that if you move
it to a different team
you kind of end up having to reset a lot
it very rarely just goes smoothly that
would be a very interesting thing to
find out with that wholesale you know uh
bargain basement whatever after thq
fallout
which was still so bizarre to me like
thq was on top and then all of a sudden
it's like good night everybody that was
the most bizarre thing it made me
realize that
giants two can fall off of basically one
one real misstep
um focusing on the wrong thing they went
hardware um and
they shouldn't have that that's that's
my assessment but i mean did they go
they would they uh but they don't be you
know that was you the you draw the you
draw
that was the graphics tablet for the for
the wii yeah i made a i made some
prototypes for that way back when what
was it like to work on
oh not
great is your eye twitching
but like i don't know i don't know what
that looks like for
you know deep silver and thq nordic and
all of that like what all you really get
when you because there was also the the
darksiders got bought and i remember we
were on set for infamous when that was
all kind of coming down and i was like
please somebody buy darksiders yeah um
just because joe madd had worked so hard
on that now he's off making his own
games too but
that was something that was really cool
that had a great it was a great ip that
just never really got a shot and it was
here was an opportunity for some other
studio to go we love this let's make
this
well it's gunfire who thankfully
made
so the team who ended up making
downsides yeah had largely made dark
side is one and two and it was it was a
lesser scale but i still really enjoyed
dark side of three yeah it was a
different totally different game right
it wasn't uh it wasn't the same it felt
like we used the name for a different
game like there's the same thing with
blood rain
graphically and everything else yeah
kind of uh it wasn't like the the like
blood rain became like castlevania it
was weird like a metroid weird
metroidvania kind of game
let's talk about that
i do want to i'm curious without looking
don't cheat
derek jacoby dead or not
i don't know what he's not i think i
think he's still in stuff i swear i
started something a little while ago
yeah i i was like man i loved him so oh
he's still alive
oh yeah
oh man
anyway
wanted to say pentamen
stoked about those accessibility options
game looks like jacob's life and death
status
can't wait to see these timestamps
but it is because troy mentioned it
which i didn't even realize
gamescom
yeah um
so we i look at us being on after the
news system
and your boys lined up ready to talk
about house of the house of the
dragonsvilles you can do that too look
at us go even children i've
stand up
it looks like it's dying when it hasn't
been watered for three days and it's
like i'll just kill myself [ __ ] stand
up yeah what is it okay just check it
out yeah it's a piece but the piece that
i have upstairs is beautiful slushious
lily is the hardest thing to keep alive
and you're yelling at the concept of
peace i love it i've killed uh three ivy
and so now
and peace i just give up on iv the
lilies are okay
it's the iv
right there that's a zzz plant
easiest thing to keep alive on the
planet you order it once a month and it
just grows
highly recommend
my monstera it's exactly the same thing
they're hardy too he's a money tree
those are a little bit harder
yeah he's doing work
i was thinking of you guys when i was
watching the house of the dragonville
yeah because of allah's hat um every
time i'm like house of dragon house of
the dragon house house of dragons house
of dragons
house of dragons got it
um they did a great job marketing that
so people know what it is
um
they to me
put on display in the first episode
everything that people were like i'm not
so sure about this and just
systematically just ticked the box on
every one of these things like are we
gonna do the dick thing nope we're gonna
chop off a penis within the show
and show it this isn't the greatest
show moving on
what is it what happened to tele like
the boys it's it's there's a there's a
theme emerging in tv at the moment
there's penis
i think it's actually some equality it's
not always about showing how no not not
showing penis fair play the
violence inflicted the grid emasculation
as it were
fig leafs on all of the statues this is
a favorite
i really enjoyed the first episode i
thought it was good there was some stuff
that i was like
background looks like we don't need to
do that um
but the whole the whole uh
labor scene
yeah
nope yeah nope yeah um didn't need that
but though yeah yeah i think that
affected a lot of people um there were
some things that and i i like just felt
this way and it could have been just
like based on the mood i was in when i
watched it it could be nothing where i
felt like they were like well we have to
do this because it's game of thrones
yeah but i didn't feel like it was ugh
we had i didn't feel like it was a
laborious thing i felt like they were
like getting out in front of it to me i
thought they were like let's
address this issue are we gonna be
violent yes are we gonna show a lot of
nudity yes are we going to
set up you know uh sibling rivalry yes i
just thought they did a lot of clever
things the use of the theme even was
kind of cool
uh they did a really good job of
introducing that many characters very
quickly in a way that made sense i have
a prediction i was always great with the
like the first season of game of thrones
right was just very good yeah i was like
what does twitter and game of thrones
have in common they both have 140
characters
um i
i have a prediction to make
is it do you think it's spoilery if i
make it i don't know what it is so i
can't tell you if it's spoilery
i think
ah mike bishop's looking good for sean
bean that's all i'm gonna say
dead i have a prediction about that too
he's the only one that feels miscast is
the king it's it's what's his name from
hot fuzz that's all i can see
considering right yeah i just
i was like
he i think he's great i just feel like i
see him i see his wig
but the other guy from gotham is that
what he's from what's what's or or no no
what's the the devil's show what was the
the lucifer that's where he's from right
i don't i don't i haven't seen it either
but that the brother
matt smith
that matt smith
doctor who doctor
yeah that's where i know i'm from i'm so
surprised that you didn't
know that i think nerd culture just
takes you out troy
sorry i have a weird relationship with
doctor who
it's just i grew up when it wasn't cool
and i i i watched it and so now it's
never been cool we've talked about it
i'm on the doctor who podcast doctor
who's never been no it's no no no no no
no but it's it it was like super like
whatever says hey you know what the cool
kids are watching doctor
now the cool kids are watching it but
it's like i it was like red dwarf and
then doctor who so like it was like buck
rogers and doctor who it was it was it
was sci-fi camp
but i'm amazed that red dwarf made it to
texas
oh man i love that show that's awesome
so lovely i'm a big red dwarf fan but i
i cannot imagine that i met that dude in
wales and i was just like freaking out
because he was literally that character
that's his name
oh you mean um vampire
um
get there vista yes
so cool such a cool and he was like yeah
i'm gonna go so i'd have a cigarette i
was like i just want to start smoking
again with you
this is so cool doesn't he host like he
hosts i think he has the gadget show now
doesn't he or something he does
something in the uk he robot wars for a
while yeah that's just fine he's also
like big big music guy too so he's just
he's a [ __ ] rock star
um i
think
that matt smith's character
will be the leader of the white walkers
he's just basing on the fact that matt
smith looks a bit like a white walker
he's a very interesting looking man
that's interesting yeah i wonder if that
is by design
like they were like we can draw like you
can see it but i i think
they also said it very from the very
beginning it sets up the timeline i'm
like damn they are really playing the
long game here because if the whole goal
is to get to the murder of the mad king
they gave themselves
a long runway to get there
like that's typically how you probably
end the series right is by the handoff
from one show to the next i think it
said it was 152 years it's like
172 years before daenerys is born
yes so that's a like that's an extra
like 15 years before the tv show
no it's further back than i think no i
thought it was further no because
because uh jamie ladies and gentlemen i
have i have the right like encyclopedia
yeah so it was it was
oh so you're way back then and uh maybe
there's been multiple mad kings this is
going to suck i'm not a person who knows
a ton about game of thrones this is
going to drive people there's people
that are freaking out right now that are
just like uh robert baratheon didn't
it was jamie that killed
jamie lannister killed and then before
robert baratheon
i don't even think they were like how
long
why did they not take it back
oh no i know this like there is a point
in my life where i would have no whole
thing sorry there was a
or seven years to be on top
you had your time
um i i know i think there was a whole
conversation between um it was jaime
lannister
yeah i knew that but the reason why
robert baratheon became king
there's a whole conversation between he
and ned stark about that about it i
thought it was because it was like
destabilized and he basically took that
moment of weakness as an opportunity and
yeah oh okay so go jamie lannister was
one of aries targaryen's kingsguard so
that's where i was confused is that
jamie lannister was in the service of
them yeah he was king that's how he
tried to realize that i thought he was
like working for the baratheons for some
stupid reason because i'm just
remembering the entire show so long ago
so long ago
yeah we were so into it dude we would
up until that last season i thought it
got
the most cultural juggernaut it's so
disappointing because you had something
that was so [ __ ] good that just went
but honestly the thing that i think made
it so good and
what i'm hoping this thing is again
is the return which has already started
to to become a trend more like event
viewing
and
water cooler talk and being able oh
hello everybody this is austin wintery i
am definitely in my studio
i love this
list and logo in there hey there he is
i am clearly here still in burbank
yes exactly g'day mate yes with the logo
stolen straight off of a [ __ ] youtube
thumbnail yeah
quick question why did robert baratheon
become king and not one of the
lannisters
well he married the lannister that was
shut up
mike after damn it
it's six in the morning i don't know
what the time has to do with it
i'm literally just here to say hi and
then i gotta go that is the most
believable performance you've ever given
that was beautiful
dude it's been an epic episode robert
claimed the iron throne because he
started the war and killed prince
rhaegar personally
oh rachel was the only killer
rhaegar the horrible i remember that
we figured it out thank you austin how's
australia thanks austin
it's good
it's very upside downy that's yeah
we called it
that's a callback and you don't even
know it i was like austin's gonna come
in here and i was like well we're gonna
have to flip his video because if i can
do that i would if i could no i don't
know you can do it i don't have that
ability do it in post
tell my country people that i said hi
all of them yeah they all keep asking
why you're not with how's it lorna
how is she getting on there every time i
ever meet a composer they're like
where's austin and i'm like
he's the only one you know i mean i
don't know i don't know it's like in
boston yes bothering to meet other
composers to begin with so
i know i know
i apologize
uh but sometimes i do and they always
ask about you like it's it's like we're
related
are you it is the same it is the same
here everywhere are you even allowed to
be here without her
like i need i need like a local
oh you need a visa there austin to be
here i do know a lot of pierce
you need a visa
yes i have a mastercard so i think i'm
okay i got my green card yeah i pick it
up tomorrow
your green card oh that's what does that
mean
it means that i am legally a resident of
the country i've resided in for the last
seven years
[Music]
yeah it turns out that uh
the spoilage that one experiences with
an american passport that basically
makes all borders open borders for you
like how insanely spoiled we are
um
australia was like
not so much uh and
yeah i had no idea how to download it
made me realize the prior times i've
been here i was like brought here by
like an orchestra or whatever and they
took care of it and i didn't realize
because yeah i'm standing at the
counter at lax checking in and they were
like your passport's not scanning you
probably don't have the visa and i
thought oh my god i'm
like most visas don't go through
instantly
but they actually do have a system to to
make it go the median one does almost
the us one does too actually
yeah i've done an esther the canadian
one while at the airport
i've done an estimate for this one they
wouldn't let me leave la until it was
taken care of damn solid
i was impressed
you guys in the comments you might have
all the comments yeah just nice to
acknowledge it i'm i'm just i'm i'm just
the first commenter that's my view of my
role i'm not gonna even hang out i'm
just the first audience member to this
podcast that's what i'm here for uh
austin why are you in australia for uh
i'm doing work
making music all come to light
eventually
cool
work
yeah i'm doing some recordings um with a
certain australian based development
team that i am known to be collaborating
with uh kylie minogue and um
and uh but yeah it's david cage
do you have a good david cage story
about getting drunk and uncomfortable
with david k justin i do
yeah sadly i can't hold a torch to
troy's but um
uh no it's it's been awesome you know a
few days i walked
the day i got here i walked the entire
width of melbourne which was awesome
um spent like night 50 feet turns out
it's only 50 feet pretty big
but it's not wide it's pretty big
yeah i know it was like a six-hour walk
it was awesome you are a walker when you
travel you do walk quite a bit that's
great it's great best way to experience
it oh that's a thing i was like and get
hit by a car i had to go check out the
studio um at
about 11 00 a.m and then uh skits things
set up and then but it only took maybe
an hour and then it was like oh i have
drinks you know at like five or six or
whatever with a friend
um
and decided you know what i'm just gonna
i'm just gonna walk and see what happens
and i i it was quite lovely that's
awesome
yep it was like apparently the one clear
day this month because it has been very
rainy
and yeah the weather sucks
especially this time of year apparently
it's terrible it gets really really cold
and it's raining all the time and it
changes ten times in a day it's it's
it's [ __ ] house as they would say it's
actually quite shockingly cold like i
was like i don't know if my old like
youth colorado
thick skin is just long gone from living
in l.a you acclimated
i think so yeah because it's been
[ __ ] freezing at night yeah it's cold
um well thank you for joining us have
you seen house of dragons no it came out
while i was here have you seen house of
the dragon
yes you've seen uh brother card have you
have you played yahoo is there cody
alive or not
i have not played a single yakuza game
oh you should they're so good
um
i have to be right back
i will be right back okay she's gonna go
throw up this is what we do yeah
it kind of looked like it at the end
of the day did i just call it i hope i
didn't that'd be terrible yeah that'd be
awkward the question is
i hope she's still recording uh sure
she's still recording did you hear this
dune open world game not hear it but
like to hear the news about it it's not
like it's an audio only experience
i have no i am so behind because the
thing is i'm in such a different time
zone that basically everything happens
while i'm either yeah but you're still
on planet earth
not really oh
i guess that's true
um yeah sadly not i actually do have to
bounce i just real i just realized i had
like a minute uh and i was like you know
what i'll say hi assuming that they're
in there and i just clicked it it's
hoping this is we're in here
trapped
i know exactly you've actually been
doing like a 36 hour marathon i'm like
general zod
oh nice floating yep nice
um so yeah i i thank you for indulging
me just interrupting you mid-sentence
whatever it is i guess
nothing important
and i'll uh catch you next time
sorry dude
it was a fleeting visit oh
well good luck with it how long are you
out there for another couple of days six
years okay
six years
he's been sentenced to normally
yeah normally it's like 24 hours
yeah no i yeah the luxurious thing
of the like you know in and out in a day
even if it's a long flight i still
typically
kind of
you know
don't overstay my welcome but this time
is
uh you know a solid week so it's it's
i like i like early morning austin
just all business
yeah no i haven't ever i haven't had
zero coffee today yeah so you're seeing
me in a like a you know normally you
have to be propped up i'm actually
impressed it's more like excellent oh
god it's like bernie just got to get him
up
yep yep i'm being operated by
marion
you're being operated by yourself that's
the you know
we're saying
he's being operated on by himself he's
like in ronan that's scene with de niro
no
you stitch this up love it i'm gonna
pass out
enjoy discussing discussing ronan
the score
the score for which elia smirl
uh claimed to be the guy that introduced
the armenian duduk to hollywood scoring
and thus
hans stole it from him it's just he
stole the show he stole which i promise
i don't understand just obviously just
just in that in that with the fact that
how do you know that
it's not like you're also and you're
dumb at math
you're you're like you it's not like you
know you only have one he's bad at
something
we don't know what it is yet but he's
about something
he had just ties his shoes he can't do
it
believe me there are plenty of things
like that absolutely yes he's actually
meant to be in france he's terrible at
traveling
i am i'm incredibly inept at more things
than nothing i missed again
other places it's like the bad first
pitch to quantum leap it's like what if
what if it's a guy that's just really
bad at traveling
they're finally bringing that back
aren't they they are and i am so excited
about it
star on it troy you got to go do a guest
star go go be on quantum leap
i'll buy austin
i hate that guy he's jerk
just terrible chest that's terrible
just goes on and on interrupts everyone
all the time so smart [ __ ] i know
that's the main thing is i can't get a
word in edgewise because he's always
interrupting
like yabbermouth it's like dude
jabberwocky try and tell a story here
come on i know
interrupts
i honestly would love i really hope that
the quantum leap show is good there's
been a lot of nbc reboots that have not
been
um and i'm hoping that this one i i
think they're are they doing a little
gender flippies on it isn't that what i
understand it might be isn't it a uh
it might be oh no
i mean at the sam beckett so you
absolutely can easily do that can't you
if it's or is it no it's a sequel isn't
it it's like set years later picking up
30 years after the original quantum
sleep the new iteration stars raymond
lee
as dr ben song
hopefully i'm saying that correctly who
follows in the footsteps of scott
bakula's dr sam beckett by restarting
his time traveling project and taking an
unauthorized journey into the past the
question is
i sam disappeared didn't he because sam
got pic got basically god talks him into
carrying on going right that's the end
yeah that they they let they kind of
play those for the show from the 90s i
guess but like yeah i'm back did you did
you
did you have to throw up
no
okay no i'm okay thank you
all right you look like you're about to
throw up that's just my face
um
that's what i knew how was she with one
she had a face that looked like she was
gonna throw up she was beautiful just
have this
yeah
what's that glow i need to vomit
uh we finally got rid of austin i was
like he's just oh i wouldn't shut up
how's he doing
great guy we didn't ask we didn't ask we
weren't that interested to be honest
only get in his personal business yeah
exactly like it's not we don't want to
get too close
we don't want to easy keep it
professional yeah but he hasn't watched
this is being recorded
every episode yeah
i do have to go
i do have to go
sadly then let me rapid fire the news
there's been teaser trailer from
developers build a rocket boy games
which includes a formerly developer gta
series at rockstar games leslie benzies
people have been very excited to find
out what lizzy's been working on they
have announced a game called everywhere
it's an open world game that is uh
aiming to blend thrilling gameplay
creativity adventure and discovery in a
multi-well gaming experience i feel like
they could have a workshop
a little bit as well our new open world
gate what do we call it uh uh hurry
hurry hurry
everywhere well i don't wanna know you
see the trailer it's just like i haven't
yet it's literally like the promises
it's everything it's every game ever
everything everywhere all at once it
says multi-world gaming experience which
sounds cool
that looked like it was 20 different
games so good luck to them it sounds
really interesting yeah as troy
mentioned dune awakening got a trailer
that is an open world survival mmo set
in the dune universe have there been
other dune games
no there's been a lot there's been a
couple of rts's yeah there's also it
looks strikingly like my friend gideon
emery and i texted him at the very
beginning of the podcast uh to confirm
and i was like i was like dude is that
you and he goes i don't think so
um i'm like you need to check it out
because it looks
strikingly like gideon emery wow it
happens
i um just did an interview with elias to
fexus for uh another new podcast that i
started and i was like yeah you're into
that
i did say i never asked for this to him
i love his voice beautiful
he's a good he's a good dude but also
his voice is just like whenever he talks
like hey troy how you doing oh my god
that's just how it sounds
you just swallowed a chain and i was
like you did ask us how did they do that
if you haven't seen that game it's like
it looks like a series of images but
they actually shot it um turns out like
a movie and uh i was like yeah that was
you right or your likeness and he was
like no that was some other guy who just
happened to kind of look like me and i
was like holy [ __ ]
it's completely unrelated he was cast
after they had shot a lot of it he just
happened to look like the guy and i was
like i guess that's probably how you
find voice matches a lot of the times
in theory he looks like that guy like if
you look vaguely something you'd think
that your voice would suit you i don't
know
not necessarily yeah people tell me my
voice doesn't suit me sam lake that's a
good example
that's true
that is true
um sony has revealed the dual sense edge
for playstation five finally all new
high performance ultra customizable
control of the playstation yeah it's
been like a while holding on for one of
those very cool ideas i think the dual
sense is
one of my favorite controllers ever so
excited to try this out i thought you
were saying jewel sense and i was like
is that jewelry sense
uh we pronounce d as j
yeah you also say
there's no h and assume how do you
pronounce tissue you piece of [ __ ]
no i don't
piece of [ __ ] is something different
piece i wouldn't pronounce the t tissue
piece of [ __ ] what do you pronounce
would you please hand me a piece of [ __ ]
i've just sneezed i need a t i need
tissue
ss does not make shh
it doesn't tissue troy
why can't i didn't assume isaiah tissue
thank you
yeah you're right you're right you're
right you're right it always waits me
out when people say tuesday instead of
tuesday
tuesday tuesday i'm gonna come over on
two no one says wednesday today
we also mike how do you pronounce the
video platform in which we publish this
podcast
youtube youtube youtube right
youtube youtube
no that's not how the word spelled
i love what's happening right now it's
breaking my brain in the coolest way
it's a [ __ ] up language
english does not make sense i'm 789 days
into french french makes way more sense
i just have a lot of trouble with the
gendered objects
and what oh it's yeah there's some
terrible thing what is a wife called a
woman
same word for wife and woman but it's
also like how do i know how do i
remember if a table is la orla
you get a sense right i think i've
talked to people i've asked people for
whom these languages are like and it's
just like they just have a sense of the
gender of things which is a fascinating
concept there's nothing about it
of course that's a masculine or a
feminine like it's it's
like it's weird like yeah it's like
something if you've grown up with it in
the same way as you understand
intrinsically certain things about how
you understand how to pronounce a new
english word even though english
pronunciation is just all over the place
uh if you're a speaker who's grown up in
a country where i just rearranged my
whole view of that so then it's like
gender is a very restrictive way of
speaking about it obviously that it's
it's probably that like there is
something about a certain object that is
perceptible
in a way that can you know
expressed in language there's got to be
a rule
that's possible as well in other
languages you have multiple you have
more more than two genders don't you as
well yeah in german you've got neuter
yeah um sorry and i think there's some
which are like five or six genders and
stuff like that which is
yeah just a sense yeah like eu humans
are weird our brains work funny yeah
we're garbage um eucalysta protocol
gameplay not garbage i haven't seen it
yet very excited about that game lords
of the fallen gets new title and trailer
i never played lords of the fallen it's
still on my shelf downstairs has is it
something i should go back and play
it's a pretty trailer but it was a
pre-rendered one so i don't know how
that equates to the gameplay because the
trailer was very pretty played the first
game i've not played the first game
though i have it sitting downstairs and
has i've had it for a long time i should
maybe give it a try
new animated batman show that was
supposed to be coming out i i read out
that's cool uh um moving on
no no got cancelled
the hbo axe falls again another one
yeah
this was supposed to be the one
bringing uh the hbo stuff has been nuts
which which which character were you
playing in this one you've played
probably barbara gordon at this point
like i don't know you must be running
out of characters as i understand it and
please
i'm no way speaking for warner brothers
batman dc anybody in particular but this
was supposed to be the one that uh
that bruce tim was doing so it was like
kind of like
the spiritual successor of the animated
series
yeah i'd love to see more bruce turned
batman
i freaked out next time man i just
i had
there was a really cool thing that we
used to always do at san diego comic con
where um they would go get ice cream
first we'd have dinner at this this one
restaurant and there was always ice
cream every night so you would
never be like like
never wanting to for someone especially
from like
old school dc or warner brothers or
whatever
here and so i i um i was at that dinner
one night and gary mariano who's the
publicist for warner brothers was like
hey i saved a spot for you right here so
thanks i sat down and i got to sit down
next to bruce 10 and i was like i
i need to be as cool as i can possibly
be right now and he's just effusively
loves to talk about he loves loves to
talk about it
um he looks like he could be greg
miller's dad that's what's funny about
it
oh it's probably a great actor then
who's your personal honor that if you
were sat down in a restaurant next to
them you would be kind of i can't mess
this up i can't mess this up this is a
hero i'm sat next to who's your person i
don't have a lot of people that i feel
that way about um um
um
charity buzz i
uh um i would care a lot about amy
hennig liking me
uh i totally understand that yeah please
like
yeah she's really cool um my like
the human i have on the biggest pedestal
i'm sure i've said this on the show
before is carl sagan jesus yes
lord and savior jesus christ it's carl
sagan but obviously can't meet him but
he's the the one human that i'm like
i just want to be that dude
who would be very against you holding
them up as a day it's true look at me go
yeah but
yeah i'd be worried about [ __ ] up
with amy hennig um
nah
can't do it i asked her out to coffee
and she said yes and then i got nervous
so i didn't follow up
oh
she's lovely she's genuinely
really i just love to talk to her she'll
be like how how how did you do how um
she figured out she was the most
genuine just uh she's incredible
i yeah i had absolutely no pretension
like you'll just hang out with her
starbucks they [ __ ] have at the ea
campus it sounds a [ __ ]
um i didn't meet her there and she was
very friendly but we didn't have a clue
australia to have opinions on coffee i
gotta go uh new tales from the
borderlands officially revealed dying
light to expansion uh wait hold on hold
on hold on we didn't know that's how
troy fights out about this game what i
assumed you would know new tales from
the borderlands revealed
i'm very sorry i really thought that you
would have known that one
this please don't give me another fight
for five minutes gearbox new tales from
the borderland launches in october
yeah
i don't that's funny are we getting this
out of the show or are we going no no no
no
that is a that is a big world in a big
ip
we've already told our story
tell someone tell us some other stories
i love it i'm just excited i'm just
trying to figure out who's doing it
yeah crazy rhys is in it but it's nolan
i think it's being done in house our
gearbox i think i don't think it's i
think it's gearbox doing it in-house
mate that was originally made by
telltale games the sequel will have a
new storyline of new characters and some
of the team that worked on the first
tales for the borderlands are back for
its entry for this entry gearbox
entertainment founder randy pitchford
said on stage at opening night live for
my gosh yeah well well alrighty then i
would love to know who from the team is
over there because they had an
incredibly talented group of individuals
and i people love tales from bolderlands
i never played it i really should i know
i should oh my god you didn't
i need you it's so you'll get through it
so quickly people like it it's so good
um
i the writing in it is absolutely it's
really really hard to do comedy yeah and
they did i've only had a job
uh and this story is great and i would
really love to see which choices you
make can you please please please please
please do it it'll take you like a day
i should i still don't play that okay
i'll do it voice actors
you'll hate me
or my character i'm supposed to hate you
right
no you'll love reese you'll love reese
laura bailey is incredible
uh nolan's bailey's no
yeah incredible she's she's awesome
no
swoon
um all right i'll play it then i promise
it and i gotta go all right thanks for
watching play what's this one everybody
i'm a police moving around might be
leaving i'm doing this you're making a
huge video
and austin is in australia in australia
we'll see you next week
[Music]
[Music]
you